I think you've got to watch this video because you watched the first spot and
you said you would tell, yeah, I can't help,
but notice that your reactions to our videos get way more views.
So it's only fair that Jubilee media collaborates with beauty buyer,
maybe the audience can suggest some concepts in the comment section below for
now. Enjoy the episode.
I'll take it off. Yeah, there we go.
Okay. All right. I think I'm good here.
You want to like start with introductions or something? Sure. Yeah. I mean,
can do that. Jeremy is my name, fun fact. He used to live in Texas. Uh,
but I didn't like it.
I'm Jorge pursuing a degree in kinesiology. I'm Anthony.
I made like YouTube videos. I workout stuff like that. Uh, I'm Sam,
I'm studying astrophysics and I'm an air force cadet. I'm Roy.
I'm a recent college graduate studying political science or shoot,
I guess. First of all, right off the bat. I don't know about you guys,
but this guy looks like a young VIN diesel.
And have you guys seen his eyes? Yeah. Look at it.
Cause you got blue eyes. I like his eyes. Oh, you got a shiny,
he throws a good shirt. Make my way over here then.
Okay.
I get a lot of compliments. And even though I don't really take compliments,
well, I guess there's been enough evidence to where I know.
That people find me attractive.
I feel like what we should do is just say what we think we are. Okay.
You don't get to say three feet. Yeah. Can we double up?
I think three, I would personally put myself a four or five.
Yeah. I'd say four or five.
I think you guys should do get out and just say why you're at three.
I feel like I'm tall enough. Fair enough. Come the shorter. Does it go real
quick? You put a lot of work into yourself.
I thought he was gonna be number one, to be honest. So for me,
he at least has to be a three or a two. Hey,
I don't want to be like rude or blunt, but he kinda looks like a frat boy.
So I think he should be like a three kind of put a word in for myself that I'm
not a bad boy. I feel like we should switch. Like we should switch. I mean,
that's why I disagree. I think you're up there personally.
I'm content with being for four or five. I stick with five.
You're a pretty good looking. I say you're.
Too pretty cute too. Roy. I think I'm a pretty attractive person overall,
but seeing them and learning more about their personalities,
I wasn't going to argue that they're least attractive than me.
I probably feel that you should rank higher.
Yeah. I feel like it should be. I don't know if the cameras can pick it up,
but I woke up with blemishes today. I got a crooked nose.
I broke it a few years ago. Man. I've always had problems with my image.
Especially when I was younger, like around middle school, I got like horrible,
horrible acne, you know, I'm left with like the scars and stuff.
So that always like, really like kind of hurt my confidence. Yeah.
That seems like a big deal to you. But none of us, like you gotta be too dumb.
I just, because you're bigger. Like you can't even tell him, man.
[inaudible] I'll take a three for you.
[inaudible] I would say you two, three, four, five bucks. He's too.
I don't know. Maybe I have a thing for white boys for, from my opinion.
And from my experience, he would be like higher on the ranking.
I think he's number two. We've saved you on two,
three against one he's two. Okay. Yeah. It's your prescription.
I mean, just look at this guy is dripped out. He puts some words.
You can get the beanie and he's got, we forgot about the jeans. Oh yeah.
That's like plus points. He's still going to have more like more appearance.
Yeah. I wish I was a little bit bigger. Little bit stronger. Okay.
So where am I? I think it's basically just them switch.
Where would you put me were an average right here at school.
I still think the wrong and I should be like here that's because you're humble.
We noticed once he took the jacket off and moved up a couple of spots.
I don't want to take it out. It's peer pressure to take off the jacket.
I like this though. I think this is cool. Well, dang.
When I saw, when the guys were ranking each other,
it's like a first impression type of thing.
So basing off how you look and the conversation that we heard for a little
time out, I need to say they booties.
Nothing.
Nothing, nothing. We need to get the 10 minute, little sweetheart. That is,
that is wrong right now. I feel like he,
he would give you flowers by far. If I was sick.
I'd call him to take care of it. He says it like, Oh, Roy's a sweetheart. Oh,
I love him. I wanted him to talk more.
I felt like all the boys talked over porn. Roy. Honestly, I love a little baby,
Roy. He just kind of shoved to the back of the line every single time.
And I was like this poor kid just for me. And it is a general whole, I was like,
well, my wanting to go hang out with right now.
Like if we were done after this and we went to, I'd be like, go grab coffee.
My number one would be spill the tea killer.
He looks like a bootleg. Michael B. Jordan.
So he will go first. Michael B. Jordan
[inaudible] or he has a nice haircut.
I guess I felt like I had a very friendly vibe from him,
just his like eyes and his smile. I thought Sam was the most attractive to me.
He wasn't striving to be number one. He was just like, place me where I am.
And I'll take that. I feel like he's friends with his mom and I did that. Yeah.
But I feel like also my like cheat on you. No,
I'm just trying to think of something drastic here.
I don't know. I feel like he probably has a bad temper or something.
He punches drywall when he gets angry. Caitlin gave her one. Who's your two,
three, four. It was one, two, three, four five
one two, three, four, five. Ooh.
[inaudible] newsletter blue. Um, two,
three, four, five. Just because I'm very big on height. I would go one,
two, three,
sorry, immediately.
I liked the guy in the green shirt who was shorter made eye contact.
And I was like, okay, cool. Like,
I think that's attractive is like connection one, two, three, four,
five. Yay. Okay. I mean,
I feel like I like a guy who is not so skinny just because I like, you know,
protect you. I don't want to break them.
I really like his eyes. Okay. He's for sure one. Yeah.
Yeah. I think yeah. Or two or three. See, I think our hand
Jorge, Jorge. How dare you? I really adorable.
I don't really like anybody's outfit today. I understand.
We're all comfortable. I dunno. I think dressing is important. Yeah.
That's fair. Can't make me picture them naked. That's weird. Do it.
Sure. We go and suck it and then everyone would scooch as everyone. Let's see.
Yeah, let's do it. Okay. Right. Yeah.
Yeah.
I would just like to say what a little angel.
Angel get somewhere. Not
little wings protective.
I care more about what the girls thought than the guys,
but that's just my own.
Wait, so can we just move up because I, he can't be there.
You little angle for personnel. Yeah. White shirt and white screen.
I would switch, like you heard the ladies.
I kind of feel like maybe they should switch. Yeah.
I am a hundred percent. Okay. With this lineup,
I feel like I'm walking with this.
I felt like we did a pretty fair job. Most of the us came to a consensus on it.
It did definitely feel a little degrading and a little uncomfortable.
Don't get me wrong. I don't want to be mean,
but I didn't find any of them attractive.
So it was kind of a lot harder than I anticipated outside of this.
I wouldn't not have looked at any of the guys.
I will walk past each one of them,
but being in the same room and seeing this type of
personalities that they have, these are some nice guys to be friends with.
Well, we are real different. Real,
mostly goes where a more personality base, which is good. But I mean,
it's still, you can't know.
I thought I was going to be lower.
I stayed two throughout the second two rounds. So I'm content with yeah.
To track. There is a guy who is attractive, but thinks he's not,
someone's looking at, at my confidence. They were like,
maybe this person isn't nice. Or maybe this person,
I wouldn't take him home with my family.
People make all those assumptions before they even know anything about you.
So it's cool to see what people see outside of you.
Your point of view,
being judged by other people based off like a minute is kind of like,
give me like a little bit of anxiety to think that maybe we do that
subconsciously towards other people.
Growing up Mexican and being Latino attractiveness is set around this like image
of being like, just really like macho, muscular, you know, Bronx,
chiseled man with like facial hair and stuff like that.
I don't typically see myself or like associate myself with that. So I don't,
I don't think I'm all that adjective.
I do not know what the women are looking for because apparently I have some of
it and I hope I figured out what that is.